very good games and let's tell you
everything you need to know about what's
happening from an
injury standpoint the san francisco
49ers
at this point it's probably easier to
shireen uh shireen to just
list the guys who are available not the
guys
who aren't available the laundry list
has gotten longer and longer and longer
for the san francisco 49ers and now
tight end george kittle
is out he will not play that's kind of a
surprise because he seems like the guy
who will will himself on the field i
wonder how much
the concerns about the quality of the
turf at metlife stadium factored into
the decision to give him another week
off
but no george kittle but you know what
that's not necessarily bad news for the
49ers because jordan reed
has been more than capable as a
replacement
yeah you know mike the best stat i saw
was of the 46 players who took one snap
in the season opener for the 49ers 11 of
those players are not going to play
this week and they're big names they're
not just random guys they're not guys at
the bottom of your roster they're
all those big name guys but nick mullins
will
will need making his first start in two
years we'll need that
tied in and it's unfortunate he won't
have george kittle because
when he did play 29 percent of his
passes went to george kittle
and and kittle in the eight games he
played with nick mullins kind of that's
when he started coming to his
into his own because nick mullins just
kept feeding him and he's smart enough
to feed him so i think jordan reads
if you haven't been fantasy i would
recommend playing them this week because
nick mullins loves the tight end
and with george kittle there jordan
reed's gonna have a big day
nobody cares about your fantasy team but
let me tell you this i've got him in
both of the leagues i'm
in i saw it coming jordan reid roll the
dice another week and i talked to him
after his two touchdown performance
against the jets and he told me how
close he came
to walking away from football and it was
the 49ers post-season run last year that
inspired him to come back
he was drafted by washington when the
shanahans were there so that connection
to the offense
existed and even though mullins
and jordan reed haven't worked together
before they both know the offense
and reid if he does what he did last
week will be a good target for nick
mullins in their first game together
uh well and you know what well mullins
played the second half he may have
thrown one of the touchdown passes i
have to go back and
and look at the box score but they
already have played part of a game
together i forget
that mullins played half the game last
week so they do have some experience
so that's good news for the 49ers and
the best news is they're playing the
giants without saquon barkley you know
and any of the nfc west opponents if
they were facing them this weekend
we'd say they're probably done this is
the perfect
spot in the calendar for the 49ers to be
going through these injury issues
because they got the double dose of the
crappy new york teams
yeah and i'm really excited to see jared
mckinnon i mean this is a kid that we've
rooted for to come back from all his
injuries over the last two years
and get a chance to play and of course
he's been buried on the depth chart
behind
kevin coleman and raheem moser well he's
going to get his chance this week he and
jeff wilson are going to get to carry
the ball and
i i would think we're going to see a big
dose of those running backs
in this game this week too so excited to
see him play excited to see jordan reed
play come back you root for guys like
that who've been out and get a chance to
come back and and make good again
yeah big contract for jared mckinnon
after the 2017 season torn acl just
before the start of the 2018 season and
then
he ended up being shelved again in 2019
because that that knee just hadn't
completely healed now he's getting his
chance as the lead guy
at least for this week and that's the
kind of offense where if you come in and
play well
it's it's it's hard to get you off of
the field and
it's kind of like your job as long as
you continue to show that you deserve to
have it
the packers deserve to be 2-0 based upon
their offensive explosion to start the
season
one of only a handful of teams in league
history to have more than 80 points and
more than a thousand yards of offense in
the first two games of a season
here is coach matt lafleur talking about
the challenge that the packers face this
weekend
in a superdome that will have at most
750 fans present
do you feel at all you guys catch a
break uh
by not having fans or limited fans in
tough road venues
in u.s bank and now and now the
superdome
well yeah it definitely makes it more
challenging for the offense especially
when you're going into places that are
known to be
extremely loud where it's hard to
communicate
but i think a lot of visiting teams
right now are catching breaks
well the ball comes out extremely fast i
feel like they've always had a great run
game
they've got playmakers all over the
field kamara
um you know we'll see what what what's
going on with michael thomas but
uh jared cook there's there's um
a lot of playmakers there obviously you
got a hall of fame quarterback
i think their offensive line is is
pretty darn good as well it's one of the
better lines so
um and i think just schematically you
just look back
at over the course of these years um
you know there's their team that
everybody in the league watches
because their staff does such a great
job of getting
just explosive plays and are able to
generate points year in year out
the green bay packers gonna have to get
it done though possibly
likely whatever i don't know what
doubtful means anymore they changed the
categories a few years ago they got rid
of probable
questionable now technically includes 99
to 51 percent available doubtful is
anything less than 50 percent
doubtful is the designation that's been
given to devante adams with a hamstring
injury
and i look he he was dominant week one
against the vikings last week he exited
early with the injury the packers still
were able to roll up a bunch of points i
think the receivers are sufficiently
comfortable in this offense and more
importantly the quarterback aaron
rodgers is sufficiently comfortable that
it's not something that's insurmountable
especially against the saints defense
that is far from dominant and you know
as lafleur said a lot of road teams are
catching breaks early this year but if
you're gonna catch breaks
it's nice to catch a break when you go
to minnesota and go to new orleans two
of the loudest stadiums in all of
football when fans are actually there
no question about that the home field is
not quite the home field
that it once was in new orleans but the
best thing for the packers is they
played without devonte adams for four
games last season
they went 4-0 they averaged 32 and a
half points per game which was the
second most
in that four game stretch in the nfl so
they've done this before they know how
to get it done and
you know i think devonte adams is one of
the most underrated players in the nfl i
don't think we give him or at least i
don't give him enough credit for for
what he's done
17 catches already this year for 192
yards and two touchdowns and that came
mostly in that first game as you said he
left early
last week but when you look at the
packers receivers i mean their second
leading receivers running back aaron
jones he loves to go to the running
backs but
when you look at the rest of that
receiving core there's really nothing
that that scares you as a defensive
coordinator but aaron rodgers is just
one of those guys that
makes his receiving core look better
than really what they are sort of like
what tom brady has done you know randall
cobb leaves and he's not the same
receiver he was when he was in green bay
and it just seems like that
with all those packers receivers aaron
rodgers just makes them better i don't
think
it matters who you give him he's going
to find the open guy and make the throws
you just better catch the ball or he's
not going to be happy with you
what a performance from aaron jones last
weekend 236 yards from scrimmage and
three touchdowns and when i talked to
him after the game
we we joked about his contract he said
yeah i think i need to hang up and go
get my agent a phone call and then maybe
he does because he's one of those guys
in his fourth year that is yet to get
his financial reward and he is proving
that he definitely
deserves it and i expect a lot of aaron
jones on sunday night as the packers try
to send the saints to one and two
making it harder for the saints michael
thomas is
out and that's not a surprise with the
high ankle sprain it's expected to keep
him out several weeks he's already
missed two games here's coach sean
payton
talking about the saints current
situation
there is not sean payton sounds so we
will talk about the saints current
situation instead
of sean payton sean payton would
probably not like to talk about the
situation for his offense right now it's
a different offense
without michael thomas and we saw last
week early on
it was clicking but then something
happened and i can't put my finger on it
it just kind of happened you know
that saints offense that goes up and
down the field and scores points was
still
moving the ball they just weren't
scoring points and once they fell behind
when you don't have a quarterback who
can throw the ball down the field
consistently
it makes it hard to come from behind so
they need to replace
the michael thomas production they need
to address these concerns
about drew brees and i don't think drew
brees is fundamentally any different
than he's been the past four years
but the thing is people are starting to
notice that that hey
maybe father time is at the point where
he's about to overtake drew brees for
good
and maybe he's been at that point for
the last three or four years but now
without michael thomas
it's becoming a little more conspicuous
shireen i still think even if devonte
adams doesn't play this is a game that
could get out of control
for the new orleans saints because if
the packers are scoring and scoring and
scoring
it's not going to take many stops not
not many breaks of the service
to to keep the saints in a position
where
they're going to fall behind and they're
not going to be able to come back
yeah and mike i'll go back to that
raiders game you talk about the momentum
swing what happened i thought it was the
interception right before the half and i
know they'd have a couple drives in
there after they looked so good the
first couple drives that didn't lead to
any points
didn't go anywhere but i thought that
interception right before the half was
just huge you just
felt the momentum swing to the raiders
and the raiders came back and really
dominated the second half of that game
but my question is where's emmanuel
sanders you sign him you out bid teams
for him you get him you've targeted him
three times he has one catch for 18
yards
this is the time they need him to step
up they need to find him
he needs to become the michael thomas
for drew brees right now
because that's why they that's why they
signed him that's when they got him on
the team i realized it was to be the
number two receiver but without michael
thomas there
he's your guy he's got to go make those
catches and
right now alvin kamara is the second
leading receiver at the leading receiver
in new orleans behind michael thomas
with michael thomas being out
but he's got to find emmanuel sanders i
think they just need to get emmanuel
sanders more involved in this game
and and i want to see more taste some
hill i still don't get it i don't
understand
why the reps are down offensively i
understand
i don't understand why the reps are down
offensively i understand why the reps
are down on special teams plummeted
from 84 percent in the playoff game
against the vikings to 19
week two consistently down from the
playoff game to week one to week two
are they saving him what's the deal is
there some delicate dance going on
between brees and hill even though
everybody always says the right thing is
it some sort of a mirror mirror on the
wall situation and breeze doesn't want
to give up the offense
and doesn't want to have to go off the
field and let taysom hill
do what drew brees can't do anymore it's
got to feel like a knife
in in the back or or as the case may be
a pain killing injection in the ribs
that goes through and punctures the lung
for drew brees
to have taysom hill come out and just do
with no effort whatsoever
the thing that brees can't do anymore
yeah no question about it and and that's
the thing is
what happens if drew brees has another
bad game what happens if he can't get
the ball down the field
he has he's averaging 4.25
air yards per reception that's just not
good enough it's the lowest in the nfl
after two weeks since 2009 brett
favre so they've got to get the ball
down the field and
if bret if drew brees can't do that
anymore then they've got to figure out
how to do that and how to do it
delicately and sean payton i think he's
brilliant and i think he'll find a way
to do it
but it's time and it's time to take the
bubble wrap off of taysom hill
uh let him play bring in jameis winston
if you have to throw the ball down
whatever you have to do
let's not get crazy it's time to go
you don't want to see any more pick
sixes right yeah james winston
is the only guy who was active for the
saints
week one and didn't play and week two
and didn't play the only guy we issued a
uniform who actually did not
cross the white stripe and go on to the
field either week but i
look i know this taysom hill was the
best player on the field for the saints
if not the best player on the field for
either team
in the playoff game and that to me was a
sign of things to come
and yes maybe eventually he becomes the
starting quarterback but until then
it's this bull in a china shop who can
run really really fast
and uh why not unleash him
unless the saints know something the
rest of us don't
uh i i say use this guy otherwise you're
gonna have a hell of a time
outscoring the green bay packers come
sunday night and and uh it's just he's
too good and he's too much fun to watch
to have him used in limited doses two
runs for eight yards no catches no
throws
on monday night against the las vegas
raiders all right the
atlanta falcons trying to avoid an 0-3
start plenty of questions there about
the future of dan quinn that seems to be
the refrain every year in september and
october
julio jones questionable with that
hamstring injury it didn't keep him from
playing last week
but it kept him from making a catch that
would have been the dagger for the
cowboys he attributed that drop where he
was wide open
to his hamstring so uh whether he plays
whether he doesn't play the falcons are
desperate this weekend for a win
and of all the two-and-oh teams i'd say
the bears and then maybe a half-click
above that the raiders the most unlikely
to be two-and-oh so maybe the most
vulnerable this weekend
to losing would be the bears on the road
against the falcons
and i know they have calvin ridley and
he's played great and and he's been
great this whole entire season but you
need julio jones
and he showed in week one he's still
if not the best receiver in the nfl the
second best receiver to deandre hopkins
i don't think there's
too much argument that those are the two
best receivers in the nfl right now over
the last couple of years
but that hamstring hampered him and you
could tell and he had the two catches
for 24 yards and he did drop the
touchdown and perfectly thrown
ball and the trick play from russell
gage just went right through his
through his hands and he hadn't
practiced all week so even if he does
play
he's not going to be 100 percent there's
no way he's gonna be a hundred percent
so it's unfortunate for the falcons but
they're probably gonna have to make do
with them if he plays i would
think he would be on a very limited
pitch count uh this week so it's gonna
be a lot of calvin ridley again
nobody cares about your fantasy team but
you ha if you have calvin ridley i'd
probably play him
yeah he's tied for the league lead with
receiving yards right now and you
mentioned russell gage early in the week
i was calling him harry gage because i
see that 83 and i keep thinking harry
douglas but russell gage
quietly solid for the falcons and and
maybe a guy who
ends up getting more opportunities on
sunday if julio jones either
ends up not playing or is limited and
maybe doesn't take the same number of
snaps you ordinarily would
the cowboys go to seattle to take on the
seahawks demarcus lawrence questionable
with a knee injury tyron smith
questionable though you think their
franchise left tackle is a little less
than questionable going into this game
correct
i do and and i have serious concerns
about tyron smith and i said it before
the season these
neck and back injuries he's had these
stingers just over and over and over
again
had the back injury we keep thinking
he's old he's he has been in the league
forever there's no doubt about that but
he was 20 when he came into the league
doesn't turn 30 until december he's
still a young guy but these
injuries really are starting to catch up
with him and it's been a really long
time i think 2015 was the last time he
played a full 16 game season and he just
keeps having
these same injuries neck and back neck
and back i just don't think he's going
to play i think it's going to be brandon
knight again
at left tackle for the cowboys the good
news for the cowboys the seahawks don't
have the kind of pass rush they once did
but their defense
still good enough to give the cowboys
some fits if things are clicking but
they did give up 35 points
to wait 30 points to the patriots in 25
or 28 what was it 38.25 the first week
so they've given up 30 and 25 points
in two weeks this season